envoyez un courrier vendredi pour dire
aux éleveurs a goûté on est désolé on ne
comptera pas en participera pas la
cotation lundi peut-être même pas je dis
donc c'est ce qui va se passer demain
malheureusement ça n'est pas très
sérieux donc sur la forme je condamne en
revanche moi aussi j'appelle à la
responsabilité et j'appelle sur tout
l'ensemble des acteurs à se dire
essayons d'y voir clair et faisons en
sorte que des solutions émergent alors
il ya des solutions de court terme
ça passera sans doute par un coup de
pouce pour la filière française qui
aujourd'hui subit quand même une
distorsion fort par rapport à ses
voisins mais ça passera aussi par des
mesures de moyen long terme on peut pas
avoir en france des salaires supérieurs
à nos voisins on peut pas avoir des
conditions environnementales et sociales
supérieures on peut pas vouloir des
normes particulières et ne pas s'en
donner les moyens
mais la première mesure que je demande
et nos concitoyens la comprennent il
nous le dit chaque jour c'est d'abord
qu'on informe le consommateur lorsque le
consommateur est informée sur l'origine
du produit
c'est à dire un produit d'origine france
il accepte les quelques centimes
additionnels faut bien savoir de quoi on
parle aujourd'hui si vous me permettez
on parle d'un de centimes par tranches
de jambon c'est ça l'objet de la
discussion ce soir ça n'est ni plus ni
moins mais c'est ce qui peut permettre à
cette filière de rester vivante et
surtout aux éleveurs encore une fois de
rester dans la course par rapport à
leurs voisins
que voulons-nous dans ce pays moi c'est
aussi la question que je pose ce soir